un autre invité politique ce matin c'est
frédéric péchenard vice-président du
conseil régional d'ile-de-france et il
ya en charge de la sécurité est
également vice président du parti
les républicains bonjour frédéric
péchenard bonjour vous êtes avec nous
pour un entretien de 20 minutes une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale qui représentait ce matin par
ouest france et par vous patrice moyon
bonjour bonjour alors on va commencer à
parler de sécurité puisqu'ils emmanuel
macron président la république a réalisé
une visite hier à montpellier dans des
quartiers sensibles de montpellier pour
défendre son bilan en matière de
sécurité également faire quelques
annonces frédéric péchenard qu'est ce
que vous avez pensé de cette séquence
j'ai pensé qu'elle était intéressante
c'est toujours important que le
président de la république se préoccupe
de sécurité j'ai pensé que c'était bien
qu'ils aillent encourager les forces de
l'ordre sur le terrain qui passent des
moments qui sont pas facile en ce moment
j'ai pensé aussi que c'était un petit
peu tard dans le quinquennat et que un
an des présidentielles après quatre ans
à ne pas s'être occupé ou peut s'être
occupé du régalien bien finalement cette
opération de communication ressemble
plus à un acte de campagne électorale qu
à un acte de gouvernement
donc vous vous diriez qu emmanuel macron
est déjà en campagne présidentielle hier
ça me paraissait assez clair oui et
emmanuel macron et été lors de cette
visite et est allé sur un point de 1.22
il ya 4000 points de deal qui sont
identifiés en france y en a 1000 qui ont
fait l'objet de l'action des forces de
l'ordre
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est cette
urgence est nécessaire que quelques que
le gouvernement s'attaque à cette
question oui alors sans aucun doute
hélas le gouvernement a raison le trafic
de stupéfiants c'est ce qui gangrène nos
cités nos quartiers et c'est ce qui
induit aussi une augmentation de la
violence parce que les dealers sont non
seulement des gens qui vendent de la
drogue donc vendre de la mort mais
également pour pouvoir vendre de la
drogue
ils s'opposent les uns aux autres et il
ya énormément de règlements de comptes
notamment dans le sud de la france mais
pas uniquement ma foi on en parle
beaucoup notamment à marseille et ses
règlements de compte sont dus à des
combats entre bandes donc on voit bien
que des enlèvements aussi qui sont dus à
la drogue et s'attaquer la drogue c'est
une nécessité absolue puisque c'est
vraiment aujourd'hui la structuration
d'accréditer organisé dans notre pays
alors vous parlez et est dealer il est
aussi les consommateurs et emmanuel
macron veut lancer un grand débat
national sur la consommation de drogue
et sur ses effets délétères
est-ce qu'il faut poser la question de
la légalisation du cannabis comme le
demandent certains maires de droite et
certains parlementaires
oui alors ils sont assez peu nombreux à
le demander moi j'y suis tout à fait le
style pour plusieurs raisons d'abord une
raison de santé publique c'est à dire
que personne ne me fera dire que c'est
bon de se droguer
voilà donc on dépense des millions et
des millions d'euros pour essayer que
les français boivent moins d'alcool
fument moins de cigarettes ils seraient
comme c'est paradoxal qu'on les
encourage à se droguer
la deuxième raison c'est que il ne faut
pas croire que si le affiches étaient
légales immédiatement les dealers
disparaîtrait comme je l'entends dire
les dealers continuerait adil et
aujourd'hui vous savez juste derrière la
drogue ce qui rapporte le plus d'argent
c'est le trafic de cigarettes et
pourtant les cigarettes sont légales
mais il y aura toujours un trafic à un
trafic de drogue
d'abord on n'autorisera pas ni l'héroïne
et la cocaïne ni la met donc les dealers
contineront adil et ça on vendra on
vendrait conditionnelle du cannabis avec
un taux de thc le tétrahydrocannabinol
sert le puissant s'activent à disons 10
ou 15%
les dealers continueront
wanda 30 ou 40 % et enfin d'ailleurs ils
vendront le même haschich que l'état
entre guillemets mais moins cher donc ça
ne résoudra en rien les problèmes de
criminalité
d'autant plus que et on le voit au
quotidien à chaque fois qu'on démantèle
un four un lieu de deal dans une cité
que dans cette cité pour un temps bien
ce que malheureusement les réseaux se
reconstitue enfin ça c'est le jeu
éternel du chat et de la souris du
gendarme et du voleur
eh bien on s'aperçoit que certes il ya
plus de points de deal mais une
augmentation de la délinquance locale
vous avez une augmentation des braquages
de proximité des agressions des
cambriolages parce que bien à un moment
donné ce qu'ils vivent du trafic de
drogue et bien commettent d'autres
infractions dont font toutes ces raisons
je suis assez le style à la définition
du cannabis maintenant je suis comme
tout le monde je suis arrivé oublient
qu'un je suis un démocrate je pense que
c'est jamais inutile de parler de ces
choses là vous êtes ouvert aux débats
bien sûr alors en tout cas pour lutter
contre le trafic de drogue il faut des
moyens de policiers et le président la
république a assuré que son objectif de
créer dix mille postes supplémentaires
dans les forces de l'ordre sur son
quinquennat
cet objectif serait tenu est ce que
c'est un bon bilan pour emmanuel macron
qui fait mieux que nicolas sarkozy qui
avait supprimé les postes
je pense que c'est une façon assez
archaïque d'envisager la sécurité ça y
est la sécurité c'est d'abord qu'est-ce
que c'est d'abord qu'est ce qu'on
demande à la police j'entends beaucoup
quand on dire
il manque des policiers je veux 15
policiers 20 policiers de plus je pense
qu'il faut prendre les choses à l'envers
quelles missions veux ton pour la police
ça c'est la première chose par exemple
les policiers les gendarmes de france
pendant deux mois ils vont faire
énormément de procurations donc vous
aimez plus de policier si pour faire des
procurations ça n'aidera en rien les
gens
dans les quartiers et vous aurez pas
plus de policiers sur le terrain c'est
pas vrai donc premièrement quelles
missions et en fonction de ses missions
quels moyens les moyens c'est des moyens
humains bien sûr je vais pas dire le
contraire c'est là la présence policière
des choses extrêmement importantes et
des moyens si j'ose dire financier dire
que la police c'est quelque chose à
sécurité qui vient de plus en plus
technique vous avez besoin d'investir
pour les voitures dans des commissariats
mais également dans la police technique
et scientifique dans la surveillance
d'internet etc
donc on assiste à quoi en fait on
assiste à un saupoudrage c'est à dire
qu'à chaque fois que le gouvernement se
déplace en lituanie va mettre quinze
policiers de plus la cinquante policiers
de plus cela ce qui n'est pas une vision
globale parce que ces policiers on les
invente pas donc on y trouve où eh bien
on le trouve en région ile de france
donc à chaque fois vous avez 50
policiers là j'ai entendu hier les
bailleurs 50 policiers de plus à
montpellier tant mieux pour montpellier
ce sont cinquante policiers de la région
parisienne qui vont partir moi je sais
une chose c'est que dans les transports
en commun ça va la région comme je suis
vice-président la sécurité avec valérie
pécresse
je suis tout les problèmes de sécurité
même si la région n'a pas de compétence
de sécurité mais nous nous occupons
beaucoup de sécurité dans les transports
en commun c'est un vrai problème
nous avons financé mille agents de
sécurité supplémentaires en cinq ans à
la sncf à la ratp ou dans le privé
dans le même temps dans le même temps
l'état a retiré 500 policiers et
gendarmes de la sous-direction de la
police régionale des transports donc
peut-être qu'il ya des endroits où il ya
plus de policiers mais en tout cas je
peux vous dire que dans le métro
parisien dans le rer parisien dans les
gares franciliennes et il ya 500
policiers et gendarmes de moins que
quand nicolas sarkozy d présente la
république alors visiblement il ya une
grogne dans la police aujourd'hui a
encore des policiers qui vont manifester
à la suite de l'arrêt rendu par la cour
d'appel dans la sphère de viry-châtillon
oud ou 2,2 policier avait été grièvement
blessé après avoir été pris à partie on
leur avait lancé des cocktails molotov
comment est-ce que comment est ce que
vous réagissez face à ces manifestes
face à ces manifestations qui ont lieu
aujourd'hui ce que vous les comprenez et
comment est-ce qu'on résout ce ce mal
être dans la police alors oui je les
comprends et je partage savez j'ai été
policier pendant 30 ans j'ai donc vu des
camarades qui ont été tués blessés et
les circonstances de cette attaque sont
particulièrement enfin nous ont tous
frappé c'est pas la seule
malheureusement tous les jours des
attaques contre des policiers
là c'était des policiers qui étaient en
garde statique il était dans deux
voitures et ils ont fait l'objet
une agression pour tuer voilà donc
évidemment et d'ailleurs il ya eu quatre
blessés dont deux très gravement et dont
un qui portera à vie les stigmates de
cette agression donc évidemment je les
comprends et je les soutiens
mais nice au tour ne nous y trompons pas
là il ya des rassemblements
la vérité c'est que ce pas des
rassemblements contre une décision de
justice
une seule c'est la globalité des espèces
de ras-le-bol
les violences ont augmenté le pays dans
les quatre cinq six dernières années et
notamment ces violences elles ont
particulièrement augmenté contre les
forces de l'ordre
moi j'y vois un recul de l'autorité de
l'état et ce recul l'autorité de l'état
il est dû bien sûr plusieurs facteurs
mais dans le domaine de la sécurité il y
due au sentiment relatif mais existant
d'impunité c'est à dire que ce qui ne
fonctionne pas dans le pays
c'est l'application de la peine alors
moi j'ai toujours dit ça fait j'ai
aujourd'hui j'ai été policier pendant 30
ans c'est aujourd'hui les policiers
arrêtent c'est bien les magistrats
condamnent mais c'est après que la peine
est peu ou mal exécutée c'est vrai c'est
vrai pour les travaux d'intérêts
généraux c'est vrai pour les amendes et
c'est vrai pour les places de prison
pour les prisons aujourd'hui en france
vous avez un peu moins de soixante mille
places de prison
en angleterre il ya 96 milles en espagne
77 mid contrairement à ce que j'ai
entendu le 1er mai entre le 1er mai 2017
et aujourd'hui il ya eu 107 places de
prison de plus et donc la sk emmanuel
macron à raison de créer une place
supplémentaire de lancer la construction
et se lancer et il avait promis d'en
dans son camp il a été élu 15000 places
de prison à l'heure où je vous parle
ghana 0 alors est-ce que miraculeusement
7000 places de prisons vont sortir en
trois mois je n'en suis pas sûr je
prends le pari ici de revenir dans un an
et je vous dirais qu'il n'ya pas eu une
place le prison construite en plus or
c'est le c'est un vrai vrai sujet parce
que vous avez les choix de quoi quand
vous n'avez pas cette peine de prison
soit d'entasser le détenu dans des
conditions qui peuvent paraître indigne
je pense notamment à la maison d'arrêt
de fresnes que j'ai visitées n'est pas
très longtemps
les trois grandes maisons d'arrêt en
région parisienne ya la santé et fleury
mérogis qui ont été rénovés friend reste
dans un état quand même qui est assez
préoccupant donc où on entassait des
duos les libère libéré détenu s'est pas
non plus devenir bon signal d'une bonne
idée ça signifie que vous avez des
magistrats indépendants sur les
professionnels comme condamner des gens
à une peine après un procès et que cette
peine finalement elle et elle est
éradiquée parce qu'on n'a pas assez de
place
mais frédéric péchenard il ya quand même
sept mille places qui ont été lancées
elles sont en chantier et là jean castex
aujourd'hui va annoncer la construction
de huit mille places supplémentaires qui
seront prêts pour 2027
ça ne va pas assez vite adieu lancé des
passes de prison c'est bien enfin il
faut du temps pour construire et prison
je vous dis moi ici que nous ne verrons
pas une places de prison supplémentaires
pendant le quinquennat
voilà et et c'est la fin de notre notre
système mais vous pouvez faire tout ce
que vous voulez à quoi ça sert à quoi ça
sert d'arrêter des dealers si derrière
il n'y a pas de répression genre
j'entendais l'autre jour un reportage à
la télévision c'était un
de 21 ans qui avait été condamné déjà
condamné par arrêté par la police
condamnée vingt-et-une fois il a été
arrêté parce qu'il avait insulté frappé
des policiers menacés de mort il prend
une peine de huit mois de prison ferme
puisque qu'une peine je peux paraître
tout à fait normal il ne va pas en
prison
il y va pas parce qu'il ya pas de place
donc comme n'y a pas de place mais on a
décidé que moins d'un an de prison on
n'y allait pas à quoi ça sert quand
quand vous avez quelqu'un en face de
vous et que vous dites monsieur vous
est-ce que vous avez commis comme fait
c'est grave et je vous condamne à huit
mois de prison ferme
dans sa tête il se dit je vais être huit
mois derrière les barreaux mais non mais
c'est pour rire vous n'y allez pas donc
tout ça génère un sentiment
d'incompréhension d'impunité
d'incompréhension chez les citoyens les
victimes d'impunité chez les auteurs et
et je pense que on arrivera à récupérer
le terrain non pas avec des saupoudrages
non pas avec des belles idées mais en
faisant en sorte qu' il y ait une
sanction en face de chaque acte de
délinquance l'importance disait beccaria
de la sanction ce n'est pas sa sévérité
c'est sa certitude frédéric péchenard on
va parler de la crise sanitaire puisque
le président de la république a annoncé
une levée des restrictions au début du
mois de mai et ce matin dans une
interview au télégramme le miz de la
santé au lioran défend cette idée d'un
déconfinement territoire paraître par
territoire s'ils ont des sondés confine
est bien de manière territoriale ça veut
dire qu'ils de france va être des
confidents dernier probablement vous le
regrettez pour moi c'est ce que je
regrette
ça je suis comme tout le monde et on est
ici sur ce plateau j'avais déjà été
invité de nombreuses fois c'est la
première fois qu'il ya pas de maquillage
la première vague a pas de café la
première fois qu' on est obligé de
parler avec un masque et ce qui est
agréable pour personne
bon c c'est la vie avec ce virus qui
nous rend la vie quand même beaucoup
plus difficile depuis depuis un an
moi je pense qu'il faut aller vers un
déconfinement ce déconfinement il doit
évidemment penser progressif
on voit bien que toute manière notre
seul espoir aujourd'hui c'est le vaccin
ça suffira peut-être pas peut-être qu'il
faudra d'autres vaccins dodo je ne sais
pas mais c'est le vaccin et on a quand
même pris un retard important dans la
campagne vaccinale je vois d'autres pays
qu'on réussit mieux que nous et c'est
porteur d'espoir d'ailleurs ce qu'ont
voyez ce qui se passe
israël par exemple ou en angleterre ou
aux états unis
eh bien on voit bien qu'ils ont réussi
avec ciné beaucoup plus rapidement que
nous et que finalement il s'ouvre alors
on apprend aussi de ce qui se passe par
exemple
en israël on on voit que depuis quelques
jours ils ont enlevé des masques parce
qu'il semblerait que le vaccin non
seulement protège les gens mais
également protège de la transmission bon
voilà 6,6 étaient avérés ce serait une
assez bonne nouvelle on en sortira par
le vaccin
il faut augmenter cette cette
vaccination
moi je je suis lui de paris celle du
xviie nous avons ouvert un centre de
vaccination dans le xviie
la vérité c'est qu'on pourrait faire
plus et à leurs jours on pourrait si on
avait plus de doses
on pourrait vacciner plus de personnes
aujourd'hui alors justement avec le pass
sanitaire qui arrivent et qui pourrait
être donc mis en place avec l'appli tous
sentis scoop tout senti que vides est ce
que c'est c'est plutôt un plutôt un
progresser on va donc on va dans le la
bonne direction pour l'instant on peut
pas tellement faire autrement alors
après on voit bien que tout ça c'est
quand même on en dehors de la crise
sanitaire proprement dit on a une crise
politique une crise démocratique on est
con on est confiné ça signifie que on
nous a retiré quand même énormément de
liberté
si j'avais le choix aujourd'hui je suis
ravi d'être là mais je serais parti en
vacances même en france je ne peux pas
je n'ai pas fait on est obligé de porter
un masque ont pu aller au restaurant
on voulait nous empêcher de voter enfin
voilà que tout ça est assez est assez
compliqué assez complexe je suis pas un
spécialiste de ces questions je regarde
juste comment ça se passe je constate
également que
la région est capable de faire des
choses que l'état ne fait pas et je ne
comprends pas pourquoi vous il ya un an
valérie pécresse a dit il faut des
masques on a acheté des masques on a
trouvé des masques on a acheté 30
millions de la moitié à l'état une autre
voiture les a distribuées aux mairies
les premiers masques qu'ont eue les
franciliens c'est la région qui leur
donnait aujourd'hui il ya un an il y
avait 1200 lits de réanimation ile de
france
un an plus tard il est toujours 1200
lits de réanimation c'est la région qui
a financé moitié avec la région moitié
avec des fonds européens mais que nous
avons été chercher 500 lits de
réanimation
les lits et puis bien sûr les
respirateurs et nous avons également
fait la formation du personnel soignant
ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre
c'est comment la région est capable de
faire des choses et que l'état lui n'est
pas capable de le faire alors que
l'étape par définition est bien plus
puissante la région alors vous parler du
bilan de la région ça nous est même
évoqué les élections régionales et
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france
quand va-t-elle se présenter mais ça
c'est un agenda qui qui lui appartient
pour l'instant et c'est assez classique
et pas de raison de se précipiter pour
être candidat alors qu' il ya beaucoup
de travail à faire notamment dans le
domaine sanitaire et dans
l'accompagnement économique et également
dans la sécurité des données sanitaires
j'en parlais donc la dernière fois que
j'ai fait donc nous avons voté en
janvier la création de 500 lits éphémère
de réanimation à l'heure où je vous
parle on est en partenariat bien sûr
avec les hôpitaux à l'heure où je vous
parle je crois que le bon chiffre s'est
il ya 420 lits qui ont été déployés dont
on en a encore quelques-uns déployés
voilà donc ça c'est ça prend du temps ça
ça occupe
nous aidons en permanence les étudiants
les petites et moyennes entreprises etc
et puis on continue à s'occuper de
sécurité se déclara au moment qui lui
paraîtra opportun vers sûr et si on veut
le mans bientôt d'ailleurs justement sur
la sécurité sur la sécurité justement
certains de ses opposants accusent
valérie pécresse d'avoir été un peu
juste sur sur le sujet et notamment
jordan leur assemblée nationale il a une
face j'ai bien
bien aimée qui m'a fait rire parce que
en fait la vérité c'est celui qui est
mou dans cette histoire c'est lui c'est
lui et c'est le rassemblement national
vous savez ça fait cinq ans le budget
sécurité quand valérie pécresse a été
élu a été la première année multiplié
par trois et puis petit à petit chaque
année il a été augmenté ce qui fait
qu'elle arrivait j'ai un budget qui est
cinq fois plus important que celui qu'on
avait au départ avec ça on a fait tout
un tas de choses rapidement dans les
lycées on a fait des travaux de
sécurisation des lycées on a créé des
brigades régionales de sécurité dans les
lycées on a video protéger l'ensemble
des quais des gares des bus on a créé on
a complètement financer un centre de
commandement unique où il y aura la
police la sncf etc et on a mis en place
également un bouclier de sécurité pour
aider les maires tous les maires qui
veut s'impliquer dans la sécurité quel
que soit d'ailleurs la couleur politique
peuvent demander à la région de financer
l'équipement de la police municipale
peut financer la vidéoprotection n'a
acheté des voitures des gilets pare
balles etc etc
bien sûr pour faire ça il ya un vote en
commission permanente au conseil
régional
jamais le front national est jamais
monsieur bardella qui pourtant est un
élu conseiller régional n'a voté
favorablement une seule la disposition
que j'ai proposé jamais son voté contre
ou se sont abstenus
donc par pitié que monsieur bardella ne
vienne pas nous faire des leçons de
sécurité on voit bien que le recensement
national vivant des problèmes des gens
ne cherchent pas à trouver de solutions
à leurs problèmes
alors je parlais de l'éventuelle
candidature de l'aide
l'airé pécresse aux élections régionales
sur l'élection présidentielle 2022 et ce
qu'elle ferait une bonne candidate pour
la droite
incontestablement elle fera ferait elle
doit une bonne à dire qu'il représentait
elle fera c'est mon souhait j'ai
immédiatement corrigé en disant qu'elle
fait parce que je n'en sais rien une
bonne candidate
après on le parti a décidé de laisser
passer des régionales ce qui me paraît
être une bonne idée parce que y'a pas de
raison quand vous surfez de penser la
quatrième vague vous êtes sur la
première donc on a des élections
régionales départementales sont des
élections pour nous un intermédiaire
mais extrêmement importante
et puis après il faudra trouver un
système de départage entre les les
candidats qui sont il ya quand même
plusieurs candidats de qualité dont
naturellement valérie pécresse
mais on verra probablement les élections
régionales sont déjà un premier marqueur
ceux qui ne seront pas réélus bien en
probablement ne pourront pas se
présenter à la présidentielle et dont ce
qui serait lui à ce qu'ils seront
moyennement bien ou très bien c'est un
peu une belle élection régionale ce sera
incontestablement un bouge peu
démocratique pour celui qui gagnera
alors vous disiez chaque chose en son
temps mais il y en a un qui voit plus
loin c'est xavier bertrand et s'est déjà
présenté à la présidentielle
or investissent une investiture les
républicains vous êtes vice-président
dlr qu'est ce que vous lui dites voulait
dit revenez dans une famille j'aimerais
beaucoup que xavier bertrand reviennent
dans notre famille mais c'est pas
tellement le sujet aujourd'hui
le sujet c'est que on voit qu'on a un
espace politique qui n'est pas énorme
entre 1000 et le maquereau et leur
assemblée nationale mais cet espace
politique il existe il existe et je
pense qu'il faut qu'il y ait un candidat
de la droite républicaine qui incarne en
opposition emmanuel macron autre chose
que leur assemblée nationale bref qu'on
ait le choix à à autre chose que ce duel
voire déjà une fois macron le pen on ne
sait pas quand même et ça ça sortira
donc il faut évidemment il faut
évidemment qu'on ait un candidat et
qu'on ait qu'un seul candidat
oui un seul candidat si on avait deux à
serait compliqué donc je pense que
chacun est d'accord et xavier bertrand
au cil quoique je je ne voudrais pas
parler en son nom mais il est d'accord
aussi évidemment il faudra qu'on trouve
un système de départage
à l'heure où je vous parle une primeur
ces jeux certains la bonne solution je
sais pas peut-être sauce les primaires
nous ont pas laissé un très bon souvenir
faut bien le reconnaître mais mais en
fait ça va se passer comment tous les
gens qui veulent concourir vont dire
voilà comment comment on fait pour bon
et si tout le monde est déprimé a
probablement au niveau primaire ou en
choisir un autre système je n'en sais
rien mais en tout état de cause ce qui
est certain c'est que celui qui
prendrait la responsabilité se présenter
contre le candidat de la droite et du
centre pendre à une responsabilité très
importante de nous fragiliser merci
beaucoup
avec péchenard d'avoir été notre invité
politique ce matin demain à votre place
il y aura christian estrosi le maire de
nice
merci patrice on va regarder à la une de
ouest france ce matin qui est consacrée
à ce projet de super ligue européenne de
football
une super league pour générer plus
d'argent et forcément ça déchire le
monde du foot européen
merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]